[Musik]
ratlos widersprüchlich ist das perfekte
symbol weil es beides kombiniert die
stadtkultur und die stadt der wirtschaft
die ungeliebte schöne jetzt wahrzeichen
statussymbol millionengrab elitäre
veranstaltung die elbphilharmonie trägt
die silhouette der stadt maßgeblich
beeinflusst die auf hamburgs kultur
lieben vier menschen firma hin zum
prunkvollen erlassen
ein bisschen ist es sein palast olaf
scholz brachte das ein verfahren
bauvorhaben wieder auf kurs
der spd mann gilt als zurückhaltend in
interviews nur was seine elf da kommt er
ins schwärmen
die empfehlungen ist ein großartiges
gebäude das ist wirklich beeindruckende
architektur die einnimmt seien sehr
demokratisches gebäude wo gibt es in der
norddeutschen tiefebene am platz der
über 30 meter hoch ist der von allen
begangen werden kann und das ist auch
ein demokratisches konzerthaus weil es
allein von seiner größe her nur
funktioniert wenn alle hamburger
hamburgern viele von vielen anderen
orten dahin kommen dass ständig benutzen
sein gebäude für alle personen
ein haus für alle diese slogan verfolgte
nachfragen bis hinter die plattenteller
red apa in hamburg ob für den tk
symbolisiert die nc harmonie die
missglückte bürgerliche kultur politik
dieser stadt
es geht darum dass das die hamburger
momente die pfeffersäcke die die reichen
leute in hamburg denn hamburg hat er
sein geld mit mit handel gemacht dass
die pfeffersäcke sicher ein statussymbol
hin gebaut haben wenn ihnen in die
eigenen taschen und dass sich bezahlt
haben lassen von allen hamburgern
das ist ungerecht finde ich vielleicht
eine andere möglichkeit gegeben ein haus
für alle vielleicht ist wirkt nicht wie
ein haus für alle die elbphilharmonie
da gibt es glaube ich auch ein bisschen
rum partizipation oder die auch manchmal
verkauft wird und das ist glaube ich ihr
das problem bei diesen leuchtturm
projekten gibt auch an anderer stelle in
anderen städten
das war verpasst hat einfach in so
genannten bürger mitzunehmen
[Musik]
der musiker und autor scheuch kamerun
gehört zu den leitfiguren der
alternativen kulturszene seinen kult
musik lob golden pudel hat er in
elbphilharmonie der herzen umgetauscht
also moore volle reaktion auf die
jüngste entstehende geschichte des
konzerns
gegen die aktuelle euphorie wir werden
das nicht vergessen wie das gebäude
zustande gekommen ist also die
herleitung werden wir weiter kritisch
betrachten konnten wenn ich dafür da es
ja nun mal da steht und dass er nun mal
auch bezahlt ist dass wir halt
bürgerinnen darf auch nutzen wollten
ehrlich gesagt die regel ist er
tatsächlich dass solche entwürfe
ökonomisch was bringen auch wenn noch so
viel rein gesteckt worden
im spiel und die meisten tun hat hamburg
mit der elf ihren zusätzliches
verkaufsargument
die stadt wird so noch attraktiver für
auswärtige gäste
was aber gelingen wachstum und
wahrzeichen für die lokale kulturszene
diese frage beschäftigt auch amelie
deuflhard
sie leitet seit neun jahren das theater
franken für die jetzt klar bei der
elbphilharmonie geht es nicht um
kulturförderung diesen schiffs ähnliche
architektur
das ist was hamburg sich von sich
vorstellen das ist wie hamburg sich
selbst sieht als statt
es ging eigentlich am anfang ganz um die
hülle ist gegen mich wirklich um den
inhalt es ging immer um die architektur
das heißt die idee dahinter war
tatsächlich am anfang stadtmarketing
beutler hardt managt ein großes haus mit
1000 vorstellungen pro jahr
sie kennt sich mit den gängigen
mietpreisen für räume bestens aus hat
die altehrwürdige live konzert sollen
wegen der elbphilharmonie diese pleite
angebracht nach oben musikveranstalter
bezahlen dort künftig zehn prozent mehr
keine gute entwicklung
mal gucken da wird sicherlich auch
irgendwelche verlierer geben
auch in dem musikbereich jetzt ist
irgendwie frage müssen die anderen dann
in schatten treten wenn es dieses
klangvolle gebäude gibt
ich bin ein bisschen anderer meinung man
kann sich ja mit in pflicht stellen als
die marketing strategie und kann davon
auch profitieren
klingt ganz einfach ob die subkultur der
insel statt mit dem licht kritik stehen
draußen fast fertig
doch nur licht ist ist auch schatten
und die elbphilharmonie wirft entlang
[Musik]